Mathilde veut se remettre en forme.
Elle trouve un tapis roulant en solde qu’elle achète aussitôt.
Il sera livré dans les prochains jours.
Mais, le jour de la livraison, le commerçant l’informe qu’il n’en a plus.
Fâchée, Mathilde tente d’avoir un produit de remplacement pour le même prix.
Rien à faire, la seule option est le remboursement.
Mathilde sait qu’elle ne pourra pas retrouver une telle aubaine.
Elle appelle à  l’Office de la protection du consommateur.
Elle apprend que le commerçant enfreint la loi.
Selon l’article 16, une vente c’est comme un contrat.
Et l’article 231 stipule qu’un commerçant ne peut annoncer un bien s’il n’en a pas assez pour répondre à la demande.
Mathilde porte plainte à l’OPC et envoie une mise en demeure.
Quelques jours après, miracle! Le commerçant a trouvé un tapis roulant pour elle…
Le fin mot de l’histoire : faire valoir ses droits est parfois un peu essoufflant, mais ça peut être payant.